allora sono qui per parlarvi di flussi
nel senso proprio di flusso temporale
per quello che ne so io perché adesso
con la fisica contemporanea tutto è
completamente cambiato ed è molto
difficile capire è molto difficile
definirlo il tempo si dice che sia un
termine generativo cioè che genera altri
concetti altri significati è più facile
definire altre parole utilizzando tempo
piuttosto che capire cosa effettivamente
il tempo sia per esempio anche il
concetto di numero viene definito in
termini temporali concetto di prima e
dopo il due viene certamente prima del 3
forse viene dopo l'uno ci sono dei
dibattiti a riguardo è trattare la
questione del tempo in termini
matematici a me risulta veramente un
compito arduo anche perché io in
matematica
ho sempre dovuto impegnarmi tantissimo
ma con risultati scarsi questo sono
stato anche rimandato più volte ve lo
dico secondo me questo anche perché
negli ultimi tre anni di liceo ho avuto
come professoressa una certa silvia
galvan una donna terrificante
terrificante nel senso che con lei era
praticamente impossibile avere una piena
sufficienza
cioè lei non è che ci desse i voti
normalmente dall 1 al 10 tipo 6
sufficiente 5 male 4 malissimo
no ci dava i voti anche negativi tipo
meno 3 meno 4 quindi chiaramente si
componeva meno 4 non riusciva più a
risollevarsi per tutto l'anno
quindi non è che ci desse dei brutti
voti ci dava più che altro come dire
delle estreme unzioni noi per questo non
la chiamavamo più professoressa silvia
galvan ma professoressa c brutalizza va
e non solo con le valutazioni ma anche
perché questa donna aveva deciso che per
rendere efficace la sua didattica si
doveva in qualche modo agganciare ad una
sorta di chiave emotiva e la chiave
emotiva che aveva scelto per noi era la
paura c'è ogni volta che ci spiegava la
sua al teorema di oakley delle rette
parallele la teoria dei limiti dietro
c'era sempre o un omicidio o uno
scienziato pazzo o una scia di sangue
questo perché lei aveva deciso che se
noi associavamo al formule matematiche
queste storie orrende chi segnava
l'inconscio ci venivano gli incubi e in
questa maniera ci saremo ricordati tutto
la prima storia di paura che viene a
raccontarci all'inizio della terza
superiore riguarda proprio il concetto
temporale di infinito
la mattina arriva in classe tra
sconvolta va alla lavagna prende il
gessetto e disegna una retta anzi una
semi retta il punto zero e la retta che
parte corre e va verso l'infinito che si
segna così con questa specie di otto
rovesciato che assomiglia un po anche
alla mascherina di diabolik infinito che
noi ce lo immaginava
come un numero grandissimo 9 milione di
miliardi di milioni di miliardi di anni
luce in fondo ea giu inoltre cioè
l'infinito in effetti è così però la
professoressa galvan ci mostrò anche
un'altra cosa e cioè che se prendiamo
due punti sulla retta per esempio il
punto 1 e il punto 2 e cerchiamo il
punto medio tra 1 e 2 c'è il numero che
sta esattamente a metà tra uno e due
quindi facciamo la media matematica uno
più 23 diviso 23 mezzi ma anche tra 1 e
3 mezzi possiamo trovare il punto medio
facciamo di nuovo l'operazione verrà
fuori cinque quarti
così anche tra uno e cinque quarti
potremo di nuovo trovare il punto medio
che sta lì in mezzo e verrà fuori
9 ottavi questa operazione di cercare il
punto medio tra due numeri sulla retta
la possiamo ripetere all'infinito e
quindi l'infinito non esserlo laggiù in
fondo alla retta da lontanissimo ma è
anche compreso tra uno e due anche lì ci
sono infiniti numeri anche in un
intervallo piccolissimo tra 1 e 1,00
0001 qui dentro
in questo segmenti know microscopico
unkrich e questo fitto questa vertigine
infinita di numeri è questo
questo cosa vuol dire che l'infinito il
tempo infinito l'eternita
ha la vita eterna la morte non è solo
laggiù in fondo alla retta lontanissima
ma è qui e qui cina anche tra 1 e 2 e
quindi noi prima per la prima volta 16
anni
avevamo paura della morte perché la
professoressa di matematica ci aveva
dimostrato che tutto può finire in
qualsiasi momento
dopo gol ma come diceva sempre la prof
la matematica è vita
se invece tutto andrà male ci
incontreremo comunque all'inferno eppure
li interrogavano in trigonometria e vi
farò verifiche sui poli no b a sorpresa
ma no prof
a sorpresa no questa settimana abbiamo
già un interrogazione di religione sui
vizi capitali e non è un vizio solo e no
solo sette vizi un sacco di roba da
studiare e poi si cantava insieme questa
filastrocca
la matematica è pesante come il piombo
qui la capisce in un anno secondo chi
come me non capirà mai ma se studi e fai
praticava diventi dirigente io
preferisco la danza del ventre della
sufficienza non vennero mai ma serve
anche all'inferno
fare dica
piccoli sapere far di conto c'è della
gente che non fa niente loro capiscono
io sono qua col recupero crediti che
però non sono soldi sono i problemi e
non risolvo questo è un dolore più
grande che ho la matematica la capirò
l'inferno di belzebù
la matematica ti serve anche di notte se
ti sogni numeri al lotto devi giocarli
tre volte tre che hanno penati similari
ma ci sono pure quelli che ti prendono
per i fondelli con numeri falsi ma la
matematica servire ogni giorno sempre di
più
bene allora grazie allora nella nostra
tradizione culturale quella che ho
trovato la più bella definizione di
tempo è una definizione che da platone
nel timeo nel timeo platone dice che il
tempo kronos è l'immagine o se scrivo
mare o immagine mobile immagine mobile
dell'eternità
ma non ho mai scritto così male in tutta
la mia vita cioè a furia di scrivere un
confronto con computer uno non c'è
guarda come diventa della carriera fede
una persona una rovina totale immagine
mobile dell'eternità
sembra una formula di una poesia
assoluta il tempo è l'immagine mobile
dell'eternità
sappiamo però che in platone le idee
sono normalmente delle definizioni di
tipo matematico geometrico sono delle
cose molto precise e infatti sia la
parola eternità anche in base al
ragionamento di prima
sostituiamo il simbolo dell'infinito
vediamo proprio che l'infinito quello
piccolo qua di ordine diverso si dice
immagine
il tempo è l'immagine dell'infinito
dell'eternità che si muove qua sulla
retta
io comunque il tempo la prima volta che
l'ho incontrato è stato quando avevo 7
anni studiando musica hanno cominciato a
studiare pianoforte con il mio primo
maestro antonio zerbato un omino un
becchino
che un giorno mi ha detto allora andrea
oggi parliamo del tempo e in greco
antico tempo si dice kronos e krònos era
un dio era un dio ma io veramente
orrendo molto crudele perché mangiava i
bambini come mangiare i bambini si gli
era stato predetto che era stato
predetto che siccome suo figlio avrebbe
preso il suo posto e quindi lui mangiava
tutti i bambini che aveva una cosa
orribile però andrea ascolta bene a
kronos piace tantissimo la musica
ascolta sempre la musica gli piace
proprio e quindi quando tu per esempio
sei a casa da solo che i suoni di
pianoforte che provi i pezzi così lui è
lì che che ti ascolta e se poco poco
vai fuori tempo
ti stacca una manina mirabile esempio di
pedagogia musicale anni 70 ma nella
musica più che di di tempo si parla di
ritmo tempo e ritmo sono due parole
molto simili
direi che hanno un rapporto di parentela
ma ci sono delle differenze perché
mentre il tempo è un concetto astratto
un concetto matematico molto preciso il
ritmo riguarda invece il modo in cui il
nostro corpo percepisce percepisce il
tempo cioè come il nostro udito i nostri
sensi percepiscono la divisione
temporale per capire meglio questa
questa cosa ho trovato degli studi sugli
insetti in modo particolare sulla mosca
lievito molo di ci spiegano come mai non
riusciamo così facilmente a catturare le
mostre cene morì con la mano ma
facilmente la la mosca la mosca scivola
via e gli scienziati attraverso tutta
una serie di esperimenti ci dicono che
vola via perché la mosca sembra avere un
concetto diverso di tempo rispetto a noi
un concetto di tempo più dilatato c'è
quello che per noi è un secondo per la
mosca è una settimana quindi non è che
quando ne moricola mano vola via subito
no perché ancora prenotare il volo si
prepara tranquilla e poi se ne va ho
trovato una piccola incisione che spiega
più nel dettaglio questa questione e si
chiama il ballo della mosca e prego la
regia
la mosca vede la mano più parte e
tranquilla si gratta non ha problemi si
prepara si lava
[Musica]
si pettina si trucca
bene adesso vorrei che e vola via perché
vola via
proviamo a contare il tempo di questa
incisione e lo mandiamo dall'inizio
vediamo se è successo qualcosa l'inizio
il tempo è molto più lento ma noi non ce
ne siamo accorti che il brano accelerava
anche perché distratti con questo
balletto che è anche roberto bolle
nureyev ai tempi d'oro
ma il brano dal punto di vista temporale
è sbagliato perché accelera invece dal
punto di vista ritmico e ok a posto
perché noi non ce ne siamo accorti noi
non ce ne siamo accorti ma la mosca sì
infatti noi siamo ancora qui mentre la
mosca in una spiaggia delle seychelles
che sta già vedendo dei cocktail grazie
buona estate a tutti
[Applauso]